[Applause]
[Music]
all right what's up y'all MKBHD here and
welcome to the smartphone Awards
so you already know we usually spend the
whole year Gathering all the phones that
come out during the course of the year
and reviewing them evaluating them
testing them picking our favorites and
recommending the ones that are really
good but it got me thinking we do that
at the end of the year is it really fair
to have phones that are eight nine ten
months old stacked up against the newest
phones with the newest Hardware like
Tech news fast we got to keep that all
into account so for the first time ever
in MKBHD history welcome to the
mid-season smartphone Awards as you can
see of course less phones have come out
at this point during the year but that's
never stopped anybody so let's get into
it alright so first up category is best
design and now there are a couple of
interesting phones that have come out
this year some of them with interesting
materials and different proportions we
do have some folding options but I'm
pretty confident with this one my
favorite designs so far of a smartphone
to come out this year is the Samsung
Galaxy s23 Ultra so this is a subjective
Award of course but I don't know I kind
of can't help it the matte black the
clean understated look I mean this phone
is packing so much stuff and yet at the
front it just looks like a big corner to
corner display they also did flatten the
sides this year which was huge for feel
in the hand I love it so that's the
design award so next up best battery and
now we already know this is like best
battery life best battery experience
best overall battery in a smartphone and
we keep seeing the numbers go up and up
which is really exciting and there have
been some phones on this desk with great
combinations of efficiency and Battery
but the award for this one I think it's
actually pretty clear is the s23 ultra
5000 milliamp hour battery in this phone
it doesn't come with the charger in the
box but that's going to be a 45 watt
Peak charging it also has wireless
charging it also has reverse wireless
charging and it's just a combination of
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 plus like you can go
1080p you can go 60 hertz like this is
the phone that can get you the two days
if you really need it I've used it a lot
this year and actually achieved that
which is rare to say so that's your
battery award okay next up best big
phone this is the phone the the award
that just goes the one that makes the
best use of a lot of space now we know
smartphones get bigger and bigger every
year so it's kind of rare to not have a
big phone but also like I think we kind
of know where we're going here this has
been a perennial top runner in this
category and that is the Galaxy s23
Ultra man this phone got the huge
incredible screen like I talked about
big battery 5000 milliamp hours and it
also still has room for the S Pen this
is something we kind of forget if we
don't use it but it's the same gigantic
battery as previous ones but also with
the S Pen inside like these phones are
consistently around the top of this
category for their software too with the
split screen stuff this is the best use
of a lot of space in your pocket best
big phone so all right next up best
small phone that's compact phone I sort
of renamed it over the years
um and it's more of a rare breed than
ever like
phones are getting bigger but also like
what is small what is compact I mean
think about it really you've got a map
of the world in your pocket a GPS
locator satellite connectivity
potentially but also a gigantic battery
a world-class note-taking device 10 000
songs in your pocket 5G internet
everywhere you go like there is a ton
going on inside of a smartphone so when
you think about it the best compact
phone is just just a good phone right so
the award for best compact compute phone
goes to
uh Samsung Galaxy s23 Ultra I mean I
know it sounds crazy but think about
everything that it does think about all
the things the songs the GPS and
everything and then shove it into this
tiny package like this is this is
compact this is small and it's got the
it's got the pen we're we are living in
great times I swear okay it sounds like
you guys do need a little bit of a break
to maybe calm down I think we're gonna
take a quick sponsor break
I'll be right back
hey are you in the middle of an award
show and your favorite phone didn't just
win a design award but the winner just
looks like any other phone well
thankfully you can make your phone look
like something else matter of fact
that's what it's called something this
is the something skin from dbrand you
can get one for yourself at dbrand.com
something shown here on the phone that
wins the new easiest phone to skin award
the very Square very generic Samsung
Galaxy s23 Ultra distinctly designed and
engineered to look like nothing before
it back to you on stage
all right we're back next category guys
pay attention it's the best camera and a
smartphone this is one of the heavy
hitting categories and you already know
the Heavy Hitters aren't out yet right
no iPhone yet no pixel yet those are the
things that come out at the end of the
year the Apple find X6 Pro is pretty
good but I'm gonna go ahead and give
this award to the Samsung Galaxy s23
Ultra see it's not just about the high
megapixel count it's also great software
processing great Zoom range with a
variety of focal lengths and some pretty
jaw-dropping features like space Zoom
like if you ever wanted to zoom all the
way in and get incredible photos and
high resolution of a totally real moon
using patented far out optical lens
technology this is clearly the phone you
gotta get okay I'm gonna wrestle through
the last couple of words real quick so
uh most improved award over the last
year version
is going to be s23 Ultra also you're
going to have bust of the year the one
you hate to give out but
yeah what the heck s23 Ultra also the
MVP of all the smartphones that's 23
Ultra you already know where it's coming
but also best folding phone a new
category
foreign
[Music]
obviously as you could probably already
tell happy April Fool's Day I hope I get
to upload this on April 1st and not get
it spoiled by all the March 31st jokes
but this is just pointing fun at the
fact that a mid-season smartphone Awards
is kind of hilarious because most of the
best phones come out in the fall in the
second half of the Year matter of fact
if you want to know what my actual picks
would be at this point in the year for
each category
here they are
it's not that many options yet but
there's some good stuff in case you
actually are wondering but take this
video as your annual reminder not to
take any headlines you see for the next
24 hours or so too seriously to double
check any images you see on Twitter for
extra fingers because AI is usually bad
at hands stuff like that just keep your
making cap on anyway the real Awards
will be in December as usual thanks for
watching catch you in the next one peace
thank you foreign
[Music]